we mentioned andrew heaney this will be
his eighth start he's two and two with a
4.62 earned run average yeah he threw
the ball so well we talked about that in
the opening last time out a lot of swing
and misses on all his pitches andrew's
been uh much better against right-handed
hitters then lefties this year 217
against right-handers machado
three for eight but of the eight two
have been home runs
already got him with the off speed pitch
a one two three top of the first
well today we get to see one of the
newest acquisitions for the san diego
padres their new ace mike clevenger will
tow the rubber now when you look at the
al ranks since 2018 look at the whip
almost just at one the er8 below three
and with the padres down scoring six
runs per game that bodes very very well
in the opponent's batting average only
219. so here's trout he had a good night
last night in a losing cause two for
four with the home run
this one is in the air to left field and
incoming is pro far he'll get there to
make the catch for the first down
3-0 pitch swinging grounds one to short
tatis underhanded to second for one on
the first that is two double play nicely
done clevenger's first inning and a
padres uniform is over a dp is mike
clevenger going out for his second
inning of work in his first frame as a
padre two down here in the second inning
franklin barretto coming up here now
swinging a miss and there is strikeout
number two for clevenger well nice
inning again scoreless after two
moreland is out one away in the top of
the third in the first seven retired by
andrew heaney and the next batter will
be cronenworth
and that one is lined into right field
of base head first hit of the day for
the padres makes up a string of seven in
a row retired by haney here's mateo the
number nine hitter
gently this one's cute up the middle
barretto touches the base fires the
second and walsh did a nice job of
keeping the foot on the base it's an
inning nd double play
first batter up for the angels as we go
to the bottom of the
third inning in a scoreless ball game
this one's pulled out to right field
that's going to get down one hops
defense will meyer picks it up he's
gonna try to go to second base walsh
that is and he's in there with a lead
off double top of the order andrewton
simmons who has hit him very very very
well over the years two on one out
he'll pull this one down the left field
line that should bring home a run
walsh coming around to score heading to
third is adele and he is gunned down
heck of a play by jerks and pro far as
the run scores
and it's one nothing angels but now
there are two outs the middle infielder
arm out playing left field
and accurate throwing arm for profane
and doane hit into a double play his
first time up
oh flares this one out to right field
will myers will die but he can't come up
with it against bile brendon will head
to second he's going to try to go to
third
and he is going to be in there easily
with a triple he's going to get that
uniform dirty as well he's a good base
runner just under the glove he gets up
quickly so runner on third nobody out
for justin upton he knows what to do
upton lines with a center field
two-nothing angels a two-hit game
corrupted
hanging breaking ball couple hits on the
breaking ball for up and
andrew is limited the padres are just
one hit going into this inning 39
fastballs from andrew haney just 15
secondary pitches but clevenger 21
fastball 40 secondary pitches
and hospital goes down swinging third
strikeout of the game for andrew heaney
went away some walks back to the dugout
too there's a lot of hitters from the
podiums they're not seeing the baseball
well out of the hand of andrea at all
yet
a couple of walks his first two of the
game two on for the first time in the
game four corner worth big pitch here on
this count you have options
and chronoworth strikes out foul tipped
into the mint angels will maintain their
two-nothing lead
really had to make a quality pitch now
for
hiney with the top of the order coming
up now
got him upstairs one away track out
number five for andrew
another one of those fastballs
above the belt swing and miss
rahini tatis with seven stolen bases on
the season this is bounced over to third
just like that
and the padres are done
clevenger move and move and move in left
foot right foot left foot right foot leg
kicking a deal and got him out of
fastball popped up right side
has back on the grass makes the backhand
one step in fair territory
mike clevenger has been fantastic
his mindset right now is finish off
moreland
moreland flares one
down a third base line long run for
rendon to foul territory goes into the
slide and makes the catch for the third
out what a play by rendon he took a
great angle to that one
nice job by rendon and by haney who's
likely finished for
the rest of the ball game it is the
eighth inning 8-9-1 coming up for the
san diego padres here's a 3-2
crunderworth strikes out
cutter
one down trent grisham is a pinch hitter
for the first time this year
and he got him upstairs back-to-back
strikeouts for meyers two outs
and a felix pena who we saw in the game
last night comes on to try and get three
very tough outs in a two-nothing game
one for three bouncer off of pena
ricochets to simmons tries to get rid of
it quickly and he got him what a play by
angelton simmons one down
what a play athletic play by simba has
to redirect and still get a lot on that
throw with tatis jr going down the line
you know you have to get rid of it
quickly and the angels need one more out
two gone here in the ninth shutting out
the padres two nothing on three hits
here's the one two
swinging a miss
and the halo will shine tonight gooby
two nothing a shutout win felix pena
picks up the save for the first time
since 2016.